get rid of those Knights because they're
The Defenders of that color they're the
only guys that could oppose you here the
computer says z0 Z down a full exchange
but it loves Black's opportunities here
because white is unable to guard on
those dark squares if he had found that
one move to follow up his exchange sack
notice how counterintuitive The Exchange
sack was well these these days it's kind
of natural but then to play Bishop takes
Knight that's where Ray didn't
understand that he had to get rid of a
dark Square Defender because because he
had that Bishop he really loved so much
and that that's what got him into deep
trouble yes that's where your intuition
is correct that's right I love I love
how you know keeping the works at bay
that's the key right yeah well also
because uh it's so compelling this
Knight on
A4 uh again with that and working in
conjunction with that Bishop on G7 going
after that B2 pawn and then that whole
queenside majority of black I I'm
shocked by the 000000 by the way of
course uh I thought that the uh Rook
sacrifice was definitely worthwhile um
and that black had good compensation uh
mauce if you could just explain after
Bishop takes E4 I was expecting The Rook
E8 to pick up a Tempo against the bishop
and only after the bishop was driven
away to then go Knight A4 does the
computer make a distinction between
which move is more accurate if you could
just show that for a second the computer
thinks that this is better for black now
it's been thinking for a while and it's
saying here if black had taken on e4
immediately and play Knight A4 that
white is slightly worse particularly
after this defense of the pawn the move
A5 guarding this Knight and then we have
this plan of playing B5 and C4 and it
will be raining pawns the computer
really really likes black here in fact
it's already giving black a three Edge
in this position so from a from an
understanding point of view Ray missed
this concept but going back to your mov
as after Bishop takes on e4 you wanted
to play Rook to E8 first I haven't
looked at this line and uh here it's not
liking black suddenly after dropping
back to G2 I guess the move Knight to A4
is um not as good it's kind of confusing
why not the same Rook ab1 would show up
and against let's see if A5 happen on
the board now suddenly oh look at this
your Tempo has cost you now Bishop F1
and there's a nasty threat to play the
move Bishop to B5 so your Rook on E8 has
actually driven the bishop back to a
good Square so deep computer moves man
this is why we don't play against these
things now man versus machine matches
are done Houdini and and uh it's like
have really shown that uh humans are
slightly imperfect but still
nevertheless we have understanding and
Ray could have played with a deeper
understanding of that position that he
should have definitely captured the
Knight on e4 so that that Knight
couldn't do any further damage as it
turns out that's what cost him the game
very good thank you Maurice for uh
clarifying that it looked like you
played the the developing move Rook A8
E8 pick up a Tempo but in this
particular case it's driving the bishop
to a better diagonal on F1 now the game
as we see on a webcam is still ongoing
Ry perhaps uh had spent a minute or two
deciding whether or not uh resignation
was um appropriate or not instead he
gave a spike check he just played the
move Rook F1 check King H2 Knight takes
G4 check why not get a few checks in
we're expecting King G3 Now by Lenderman
and I think that is the point where Ray
can say okay I gave it my best uh
nothing nothing to be done anymore King
G3 escaping any types of
Perpetual uh setups
and winning the game simply winning the
game that's right and uh I expect we'll
see a handshake on that game pretty soon
Al we've been saying that for a few
moves now so right right and monar gra
didn't turn out the way that we expected
it to okay so we thought that maybe gra
would get this D5 push in at some point
and they' played several moves since we
last looked at it wow I'm still having a
little a problem on my board so I can't
bring it up I'm going to ask Maurice if
he can fill in the breach a bit for me
I'd love to give I'll do some color uh
well some commentary with Maurice uh
we're just seeing the the the current
position through our webcam position uh
Mac did not he Mac kept his King in the
center and did not bring it to the queen
side instead he's developed his Rook M
Rooks Maurice if you could just uh take
us through this current
situation indeed the position did
proceed as follows after the move Bishop
to G5 Rook D to D7 Rook to B1 was played
here and after Rook to f8 Rook H D1 Rook
to A8 and now King the other way as to
F2 Rook to f seven and the King going
back to E2 maybe sort of a Ted offer of
a draw now the move Knight C5 Bishop
back to E3 Knight to E6 and we have this
current position Rook B to C1 which uh
is very very close to just drawn black
is unable to really get these pawns
moving this is the only thing that can
really help him or maybe a G5 break you
know even though this position is close
I can see gev sitting around on this one
for the next hour I mean sad to say my
fellow co- commentators as much as we
like to go out to dinner soon uh I could
see him just sit here for a while and
say let me see what I could try almost
in Magnus Carlson fashion let me just
sit on this for a while and see if this
guy tries something dumb or makes a
mistake and it feels like that's where
we are in that kind of Magnus territory
where you say I'll make another 20 moves
I got nothing better to do you know
let's just make some moves and see what
happens so white white has nothing here
white can't make any breakthroughs so
white is forced to sit and see if black
can come up with anything creative and
there potential Pawn breaks here with C6
and D5 there is the potential for G5 you
know that would weaken this Pawn but he
could maybe try to time that right so
we'll probably be here a while in this
position as black tries to steal a point
in this round and why not because he
otherwise he's going to be down a point
against our current tournament leader
who looks like he's about to slam dunk
his
position back to you guys thank you
Maurice uh firstly I absolutely agree
that uh this game is uh going to be a
lengthy game in the sense that black has
the edge it's not easy to um make
something concrete out of it and it's
just going to require a lot a lot of
work and it's not just uh Magnus Carlson
by the way I saw recently in aeran that
Hikaru Nakamura is playing really hard
all the way to the extreme end and in
fact he had a 50 move game against teore
rajabov as that he was trying to uh
nurse a small Advantage 50 move r a 50
move RU game yeah cuz 50 moves is about
average for you car no no no no yeah but
a 50 move rule game to make the draw I
can see that uh in my board the setup
that I can Envision for white is that
he'll put his Rook on C2 he'll drop his
Bishop back to C1 and then he'll simply
wait and he says okay you black do
something and as Maurice was explaining
the real lever in the position is to
play C6 and D5 something that I've been
anticipating that tour was going to play
for quite some time and we were looking
at lines where the Rook was capturing on
D5 right but that was because we had
like a lot of activity well we didn't
have the option of recapturing with the
pawn either true right but we were
actually getting activity with their
Rooks whereas here would be more
building a center and we have a result
Alexander lender continuing to impress
in this Championship three and a half
out of four just a fantastic play from
the youngster who missed last year's
championship right and by the way a cute
finish at the very end I'm going to uh
bring our viewers to see this final
finish as uh as Alex Lenderman finishes
the game with a flourish taking three
and a half points out of four games
pretty impressive in such a close fi we
have the final position on the board
actually just giving up the exchange yes
so kind of a nice uh a nice kind of
counterplay to robson's earlier exchange
sacrifice exactly so what we had seen uh
through our webcam was this last move by
black G5 G4 hoping against hope that the
pawn would go to G3 so that he could
play Rook H2 check and mate of course
white did not allow that to happen took
the Pawn King G6 E6 check we saw this
check by the Knight the king did come to
G3 Knight dropped back to
H6 uh pay attention there is a knight
fork in the position Knight F5 check
uh picking up the Rook on E7 have been
spilled oh tell me about it Rook uh goes
to E8 uh obviously white is now all set
toot many moves that won't win for here
for white I believe exactly King G7 but
here a very nice finish because if you
play the move
E7 um after Rook takes F7 you
don't well you can too you're right I'm
afraid that there are too many wins but
I really did like this move Rook uh G8
check in case the Knight captures Pawn
takes eal Queen check King captures
Queen and this uh scorpion sting the
Italian
Bishop lives to rule he been check in
that yeah it's very aesthetic that the
king can't come to fa or F7 and exactly
the king cannot uh stop this Pawn from
promoting and after the king moves Queen
and that was all she wrote and so Ry
thought it was a very judicious moment
to give it up wow great game really
exciting very nice play very nice
Lenderman truly is impressing he's
looking very very good we do have both
players coming to talk with us today
because we only have one game left and
it'll be also to hear what Lenderman and
Robson think about the final game that's
going on here as well oh
absolutely so they're just getting miked
up uh the player Ray Robson uh joining
us in our studio in just uh a few
minutes I'll go back I'll turn my
attention back to the current position
where I am expecting we're going to see
a lot of maneuvering back and forth um
for some time uh before The Clash
eventually happens well it looks like uh
Graves made the move Rook to E8 after
Rook to H1 so a lot of what we call
mysterious Rook moves in this position
and that that's a term that was coined
by nimich your favorite right
no that's a move where you know you put
your rook in a square it's not quite
clear why well in this case it's not
that mysterious uh because uh black has
just played Rook G8 he's fainting he's
fainting the idea that he may play the
move G6 G5 to open up the position so
max said well I don't want you opening
up the position prophylactic move right
yeah he played Rook H1 to in in
anticipation of the H file um and that
move totally discourages Rook H1
discourages uh G6 G5 because but now
Rook on on G to E8 well Rook to E8 I
believe was played Rook to E8 was the
move and I think I see that yeah and so
I guess he's trying to another NES ofage
word over protect D5 well he may once
again be intimating that C6 and D5 yeah
well again I was a little bit uh of the
mind that the King on E2 could be
potentially V vulnerable when the center
explodes so with this move Rook on E8
via sets up a potential discovered check
against White's King yeah and so we're
going to see those Rooks dance back and
forth till he finds the right time to
play D5 meanwhile we've got Grandmaster
Ray Ro Robson with Maurice Ashley Robson
one of our most talented young players
in America and a student at Webster
University he's with
Maurice Thanks Jen I'm with Grandmaster
Ray Robinson after a difficult loss
against our current tournament leader
Alex Lenderman Ray first of all thanks
for coming on the show sure Ray I asked
you off camera and asked you where had
your theory stopped in this line and you
said it was very early on in the game as
early as as which move maybe uh around
move 11 I wasn't expect I mean I wasn't
expecting this line and then I didn't
remember um if I'd seen that A3 or
what's the theory after 9 A3 so I was
kind of on my own from here on your own
but you played all the book moves up to
this point uh all these moves were were
played before Queen B3 this is where the
new move was this idea of Rook to E8 and
he played this move Rook D1 quickly
Bishop D3 had been the previous move in
the
with C4 but white was okay there too and
here you played the very interesting
Rook exchange sacrifice that is uh why
did you feel the need to do that now um
well I thought it would it would uh be
very interesting and should give me um
comp compensation and I wanted to do it
before maybe um it would be less
favorable or he he would just prevent it
altogether and so I thought now is a
time to do it if if if at any any time
indeed and it turns out that after takes
Knight B4 Knight E4 that right at this
moment you could have actually captured
on e4 and then played with Knight A4 did
you spot that
idea well I was originally I was going
to take on e4 but then uh mostly I was
thinking about taking Rook E8 and then
probably just Bishop G2 and I didn't
think I had enough compensation but um I
thought a little bit about this idea
Knight A4 but I I didn't think it would
be as strong as it really is all right
putting the Knight on the side actually
uh our colleague Yas San also said Rook
to E8 but Bishop to G2 is quite strong
in that position especially with the
bishop able to come back into the game
so difficult position uh for you from
here on out it looks like did you have
any chances after this I am not sure I
think um if I had any there
were few and slim
so I think um I think Alex navigated the
complications pretty well and held the
advantage throughout as far as I can
tell well you're at 50% it's not the
worst score in the world uh to to be on
at the point like this how do you come
back and play the rest of your
games well I guess I just have to
readjust and um you know
tomorrow's another day another game and
um I have to give all my energy into
that game and just focus on the rest of
the tournament and I just have to forget
uh about this game now indeed well
thanks for joining us in our studio best
of luck in the rest of the games thank
you Grand Master r on 50% after a tough
loss we'll see him fighting again
tomorrow here at the Championships back
to you Jen well it too bad a deep regret
that uh Ray didn't follow up in this
very enterprising exchange sacrifice
with that line Knight A4 and B5 because
if he had done that we would have had I
would have be very very curious as to
how uh Lenderman would have defended his
B2 Pawn whether he would have gone for
Rook D2 or Rook B1 big big difference
between that and maybe as we get uh Alex
miked up Maurice will be good enough to
put him to the test and ask him what
would have happened if would have could
have should have just going back and
reflecting on the game that the
remaining game of the round um we I I'm
seeing one kind of a very strange idea
in the position from Black's point of
view how's this uh um Jennifer I'm just
going to make a move okay I'm not sure
exactly why I'll make this move but I
was just giving this um night check a
brief glance because it's not that
simple for white right so now you're if
you take with a knight I got this really
sweet Nifty Tempo uh against your Bishop
forcing it to retreat and I've got this
Pawn on e4 suddenly as a crucial Target
right and you can't really defend it
with King D3 because take take and Rook
D7 Jack precisely it falls anyway and if
you take with the bishop then after Pawn
takes again White's facing uh this break
D6 D5 and in certain cases uh by the way
not to forget that the pawn on F4 gives
me access to the E3 Square so uh ma may
be facing
concrete threats in the very near future
but in the meanwhile our tournament
leader three and a half out of four in a
very tightly packed field is ready for
the
Inquisition the Inquisition uh I don't
think it's that
bad in fact the field is not so tightly
packed anymore because we have a horse
that's broken away Grandmaster Alex
Linderman who's now leading the
tournament three and a half half first
of all congratulations on your game
thank you Alex uh you play this move
night A3 and some of it looked unusual
we looked it up in the database it
turned out that this position had been
played before where did your preparation
end uh in this game after Rook F E8 so
his new move which was Rook F to E8 cuz
Bishop D3 had been played and so you are
just fully in your preparation still
yeah Bishop D3 I expected after the
which it should be equal but he has to
find a lot of very accurate mov and it
looks like not too much risk although I
didn't remember a lot of it but I knew
some ideas but here it looks like I
actually made a mistake I should have
played Rook ad1 as the computer shows I
should because then The Rook is much
better placed on F1 in case of the
exchange sacrifice and uh to be honest I
actually underestimated it so the
problem of the wrong rook in fact that
we often have which Rook to put it's
actually quite embarrassing because uh
at first I rejected rug D1 because I was
afraid of Bishop D3 but that just
doesn't work because Rook takes C4
Knight takes C4 it's a hallucination
error and uh and then Rook fd1 I
remember Bishop D3 wasn't as effective
but then I remembered I can just take
but uh it was uh but it was of course
Rook ad D1 is much more accurate you
saying you you were a little bit worried
about this move which is actually not
even playable let's get that in there
Rook takes D3 and and this Fork which
looks like a fork is not really a fork
it just just dies well okay so that's a
nice little ghost not to have happen on
the board so here he played this move
and what what did you think when he
sacrificed an exchange were you
concerned when you saw the the move
actually get played well to be honest
theuk F shouldn't be the most accurate
move probably uh and he took a lot of
time so it seemed like he didn't know
the position so deeply so I thought that
the reason he sacked was because he
thought that other other Alternatives
were just kind of worse and he just
wanted to make it complicated but I
wasn't sure if it's enough compensation
Well turns out that there was a
difficult position for you to navigate
in a couple of moves right here if he
had actually captured this Knight on e4
and play the move Knight to A4 there
were some challenges here to try to
convert this position the Houdini thinks
it's at least equal maybe even slightly
better for black could be that's that's
the after you know well the thing is I
thought 94 is the best move regardless
because I thought the other Alternatives
give him a lot of compensation like E4
potentially after after Bishop G4 my
Rook has to move to F1 and then Knight
D3 He and then he gets D5 score he gets
Bishop D4 he gets a lot of counterplay
and here uh I didn't quite see it but
then while he was thinking I then I saw
this idea and I wasn't sure what I
exactly I was going to play I was
thinking of uh Rook D2 maybe I was
probably going to play but yeah I was
actually thinking that he might have
some compensation here so I guess it's
good that he didn't play that I would
say so cuz he had great comp ation but
then but then you handled it here the
way he played you ended up being able to
just smoothly go through and and handle
the position it looked like very fine
technique I wouldn't uh I wouldn't say
smoothly I mean I it was very hard for
me I mean I I thought I must have missed
some things in fact at a couple of Po at
a couple of moments I thought I was
fortunate that I had certain resources
that I didn't quite see in advance it
was very hard for me to play but I guess
I'm just fortunate that it turned out
okay but uh very modest uh reply for a
lot of Genius moves you found in the
game uh but but it did work out for you
you had a great ending and and finished
in a at least a cutesy way you were
totally winning at the end but you're in
first it's four rounds at the US chess
championships not only in first you're
in first by a full point how does it
feel to be the leader at this stage in
the competition well it's just a start
like I said yesterday it's just you know
you have to take it one step at a time
and focus on trying to do the best I can
tomorrow one move at a time now one step
at a time but you're a full point ahead
of the pack there's got to be some more
feelings bubbling up now I have to try
not to think about that you know I have
to try to as much as I try to get you to
think about it I have to try to play
every game like it's round one and just
play my normal chess and just uh do my
maximum look you know look for my
opportunities and take advantage of them
your preparation has really been very
good in the championship or or either
either that or people just waling into
it uh waling into your lines uh has
there been anything different you did
for this Championship than than previous
tournaments uh well I think in the
previous Championship also my
preparation was good uh I don't know I I
try to prepare very well for the US
Championship um I try to learn a lot of
new stuff so that you know uh people
don't expect it and uh one game a day I
know it suits me very well uh because I
have a chance to get everything to
together my regiment my preparation
everything is in order and uh I try to
bring my aame every time here uh uh so
far my preparation has been successful
although I wouldn't exactly call it
super good because I didn't remember a
lot of the stuff yesterday or today and
in the other two games I think I
actually didn't get such great positions
as I hoped for so you know we'll see
it's uh we'll see how it goes the rest
of the way but for now I obviously I
couldn't have expected anything better
than this indeed uh I have seen in the
past I don't mean to bring up negative
memories but I have seen you start
strong in the past how do and and then
Peter out later in the the tournament
how do you make sure that doesn't happen
here oh first of all you can't get
overconfident um because uh everyone's
capable of beating me obviously every I
still have seven more strong players to
play so obviously you have to keep that
in mind and uh you have to make sure
that uh you maintain that same regimen
that you have done in you know earlier
on and not change anything to the worst
and not get over excited or anything and
just uh keep your same routine and do
your best are chess players
superstitious or are you superstitious
no not at all but you like that same
regiment though that helps no I I I use
the same regimen because it's simply
helpful for my chess but not because of
you know some other strange
reasons okay well we wish you the best
in the rest of your games by the way who
do you play tomorrow I'm playing Sergey
Arenberg tomorrow aronberg and he lost
to G today well we wish you good luck in
your games and good luck in the rest of
the championship thank you very much our
leader standing by himself a full point
ahead of a hungry pack of wolves is
Alexander Lenderman Grandmaster and uh
he'll be trying to win tomorrow as well
back to you Jen and yes thank you and
yeah tomorrow we're going to have some
interesting games because both in the
women's and the champ Championship we
see the leaders facing off against
people who are licking their wounds so
you've got Lenderman he is playing with
black against Sergey arberg who just
lost a tough game today against SC
hamsky and then the women's you've got
Arena Crush playing against camil Bahan
skti mhm so of course she had a rest day
but still right a tough recovery there
exactly in that lovely Four Queens game
against the 13-year-old is swaron Camila
was devastated by losing that and then
Anna zatonski playing against Victoria
KN who only has half a
point oo okay Anna Anna has a so could
be a lot of blood tomorrow a lot of
blood I remember playing in these round
Robins where you know with Gary Kasparov
I wanted the number just um uh besides
Gary so in a sense that I'm following
Gary in the tournament if Gary's wins I
play the opponent on the next day right
you like to follow I like to follow and
gakamsky just
having defeated Sergey Arenberg kind of
sets the table for uh Alex Lenderman to
continue his great great surprising
success and also in the interview that g
gave he got to mention that he felt that
Alex's success was absolutely warranted
and that he's been looking for Alex to
make a breakout move for quite some time
so um God when gamsky speaking highly
about your game uh and it's time for you
to beat him and Dethrone him yeah it's
serious it's serious dethroning in
possibly in place in this Championship
we haven't seen that I mean gakamsky has
been pretty dominant so when hiar is not
playing well today you know he really
showed his medal so it's true and what
do we have in the molar gra game um
we're looking at all these movers for
black to try to press um and they're you
know the interesting thing is they're
playing very quickly so they're getting
those 30second increments right and and
you seen a lot of moves and frankly
nothing has happened just a lot of moves
just a lot
of pardon me two and frowing um which is
what exactly what you expected exactly
uh at certain moment um after uh teore
has
determined the very very best setup for
his pie guess what folks he's going to
go for C6 and D E5 and again and again
and I'll just say it because probably
sometime we're going to break and go off
the air I don't like the king in the
center of the board and if I were white
I would reorganize while black is
reorganizing I would put my king I would
want to Castle I would want to put my
king on E2 on the C2 square and I would
want to take the Rook on C2 and put it
on the E2 Square what about so you don't
like F1 either because the Rook what
about Rook D1 Rook E2 and King f
right okay so and I think we can bring
uh Maurice into this conversation as
well about the game well I have to at
least express my pet peeve actually I
have a few of them about Chess but I
really have a pet peeve regarding
increments I think that increments were
probably the worst invention in uh many
years in chess in in chess tournaments
reason is that you can have a situation
where a player can just move back and
forth many times like in a position like
this and keep gaining time on the clock
it's so counterintuitive to sports where
imagine you have two minutes left in a
game in a football game and on every
completed pass 30 seconds gets added to
the clock I mean any successful play
even not even just a pass you can hand
the ball off you might even pass might
not even be completed it might still add
30 seconds of the clock that's what
happens in chess now and I think it's
it's just it's it's not uh the way you
want competition to go it's almost uh
unamerican dare I say we're so used to
time running down and people running out
of time that to see them gaining time is
a bit much and that's kind of what's
Happening Here we see it happen often in
competition people gaming the system a
little bit I know the intention of
increments was to make sure that people
didn't get into time pressure and and
then blunder like crazy but frankly
what's wrong with that I mean you know
it's part of Chess we grew up with it as
back in the days when they didn't have
digital clocks that could add time to
your uh your game so I think you're
seeing some of that here the players
particularly the gr probably playing
just a little bit quickly just rushing
his moves back and forth so he gains
time on the clock and that I think
something needs to be done dare I say
probably within the next five years
people might turn that around and say we
shouldn't do this anymore it's not good
for our audience it's not good for
chess guys I see a lot of your points
and I'm also really big into promoting
chess and making it more popular
but I also see some good things about
the increment one thing is you see less
of these like especially in like really
in in prestigious tournaments or even in
tournaments where you don't have a lot
of arbiter Manpower MH it's hard because
without increment there's just like such
jokes of finishes and it results in
these really ugly disputes that you see
very few of these days right people
knocking over pieces knocking over
pieces I mean of course it makes it
exciting but sometimes sometimes it
makes it exciting but if you don't have
enough eyes on the board it can also
just be ugly well really you got to
define the um argument by two different
audience it's no surprise that the idea
of increments comes from Bobby fiser the
great chess purist who is trying to make
the game uh as clean and as precise as
possible and takes away the time trouble
so from a player who does get into time
trouble a Ray Robson for example
probably thinks that the increment is
the greatest thing and S loves it iov
they gave him a second career but what
Maurice is saying is look if we want to
make chess popular we want to make a
chess a dramatic sport for an audience
we got to get rid of the increment for
all of these list of reasons and from
that perspective he's absolutely right
but Bobby wasn't interested in what the
audience had to think and Bobby didn't
care about he also a double round robin
tournament
most likely to determine a pure winner
first to win 10 games and all kinds of r
a smaller increment you can make it like
a one second increment or a two second
increment I think because delay actually
I find there's also a counterargument
I've heard people argue including my
brother who's one of the best chess
promoter in America the US chess League
the US chess school he likes to make
things as exciting as possible he thinks
that actually the delay can be more
confusing to a audience because it's
just kind of weird whereas the increment
you can kind of explain laain in one
sentence the delay you have to kind of
say well you have this maximum if you
use it you don't lose it but if you
don't use it like it takes a little
longer than a sentence to describe a
delay true that and I know Maurice wants
to Jump Right In on this delay issue so
Maurice take it take it one second
increment what would be wrong with that
look a 30 second delay is better than a
30second increment and it's easy to
explain all you're saying is when the
opponent makes a move you are you will
get 30 seconds to make your next move
before your time starts that's it or
whatever the delay is you get a certain
amount of time that your clock will not
move before your time starts and that's
it simple so an audience can actually
look and see the delay ticking down if
it's 30 seconds which I think is way too
much should be more like a 5 second
delay at most but if it's 30 seconds
ticking down you'll see it's 30 29
somebody understands that and then once
you're once that time that you've been
given that grace period if you will
which is what we call it delay maybe we
call it a grace period That's the maybe
the simplest way to explain it you get a
grace period of 30 seconds before you
have to move done and I think everybody
understands that I was at the dinner
table uh with uh with a couple of
non-chess players and Rex innfield and
all of us were sitting around I think
you were there too Jen and we explained
it to the to lay players and literally
it wasn't my term one of them said
increment that's unamerican like just
that plane and they understood the delay
with no effort because they understood
the idea of a grace period so I think
that the delay makes more sense it also
shortens the game because when you get
an increment you're given 30 second
you're seconds each time you're gifted a
Whole 30 but in a delay anytime you move
if you move within 5 Seconds you're not
gifted the extra 25 seconds you just you
just moved within your grace period and
that was it so I think that the delay
makes a lot more sense it's easier it
should be a short delay to me five or 10
seconds like I said but increments
that's that's just that's just even if
you can explain it easily you're being
given 30 seconds it's like then where's
the drama I mean it's it's you're down
to 10 seconds oh he moved oh he has 40
seconds what happened oh now he has a
minute and 20 seconds he's getting more
time I was like just it just I think is
is patently ridiculous now from the pure
chest standpoint like you said about
Bobby Fisher sure who doesn't want to
have a free 30 seconds put him in my
pocket I I'll store him up for a rainy
day but from a from an audience
engagement standpoint I think increments
have to go well again I'll just pick up
from what Maurice is saying first of all
uh what we're we've been having these
discussions since the very start of the
US championships here in St Louis we're
trying to be uh the home of not the
capital of not just chess but Innovative
chess and bringing different ideas such
as this broadcast I might add and how to
engage the audience and that particular
dinner that Maurice was talking about
was actually at the opening ceremony and
of all people who said it was on an
America was a chess was a a politician
who's a non-chess player and said
Charlie uh from the uh St Louis city
council he said what and I think you're
being a little hard on increments
because I think it's a 30 second
increment
which is more of the issue than the
increment trust me one second increment
two second increment people are going to
be losing on time right I mean they will
definitely be losing on time they even
had Blitz tournaments with 3 minutes and
2 second increments and that actually
goes faster than five minute chests yeah
and again really fast the increment
really does help the off the Arbiter
tremendously in terms of avoiding those
Blitz finishes where pieces get knocked
over and as you say bitter feelings
erupt uh like you know your hand
interfered with my hand and I couldn't
press the clock and things of that
nature that's right actually at the 3
minute and 2 second Blitz tournament
that I played in because you had the
two-c increment um they had a very harsh
rule um about where you had to put the
piece for it to be legal on the Square
in the middle of square as opposed to
slightly off square like it was slightly
off Square you would like for you
wouldn't NE you would forfeit you could
forfeit the game after pressing your
clock because your wasn't properly un
inspect wow exactly if I may jump in
like think about this this idea of the
increment though what you just said it's
tough on the Arbiter we have cameras on
these games like if you have a big
dispute if there's a real dispute go to
the vide tape do it like they do in
sports right now like what happened and
when you say oh there are bitter
disputes what is sports all about but
bitter disputes we love it I understand
we're a gentleman's game you know we're
not supposed to be kicking dirt like in
baseball but hey a few disputes
definitely do not hurt the ratings do
not hurt uh the viewing audience who
would be totally intrigued by what
actually happened and then the Arbiter
can then say you know I need to look at
the tape to see exactly what happened we
have cameras everywhere so I think the
more professional the game gets the more
we're going to realize that this is a a
good idea I mean as it stands you know
these guys are comfortably gaining time
on the clock that's moving back and
forth that's totally not engaging that
just does does not work and I think you
know we're thinking about the players
and we should but I think this invention
of the increment solely because we have
a digital clock is is uh an invention
that really does not help our audience
engagement like you said yes uh not at
all and I think it just has to go we've
got a comment from uh a listener who
says that this is actually not just any
listener Mark Crowther of of uh the
weekend chass a great resource on
Twitter he always knows what's going on
in chess this week he's great not just
not just this week this minute this
minute um he says the increment is
created by taking time off the normal
time control you're not just been giv it
it's been returned so he says it's not
just a gift it's a return and uh we've
got another participant um Alex Barnett
who says the best thing is to increase
time delay from 5 Seconds to 10 seconds
I agree with Maurice the increment is
gross Maurice is fist pumping in the
background and yet another comment Peter
War says great discussion about
increment and timings in general by the
way don't listen to
politicians seems like we're kind of
divided here the uh the audience uh has
a lot of opinions on this as well keep
it coming Ash uschess Champs we are
going to take a quick break and we'll be
back to see the conclusion of Mona gra
and hear more from you guys at
home
I
think be surprised be intrigued be
delighted the World Chess Hall of Fame
in St Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagine
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
worldclass art play together the World
Chess Hall of Fame mind art
experience welcome to the world of this
surreal you take the blue pawn and
return to the comfortable world of Chess
tournaments as you know them you take
the red pawn and I'll show you a chess
event Beyond Your Wildest
imagination
hello and welcome back to the 2014 US
Championship we've got one round we got
sorry one game remaining in round four
and it is heating up we've been
mentioning gra needs to get in D5 and
he's successfully done that he's played
C6 and D5 and he skillfully done it at a
time when MC Muller has very little time
on his clock and indeed uh we were all a
fire a moment ago as Muller's clock Max
clock was ticking down and and uh
Maurice was saying we got to get back on
air look at this look at this suddenly a
move was played and he suddenly had a
minute on this clock and it was like I
rest my case about increments well at
least the McKenzie Moulder will be in
time pressure for a while that that is
one upside he's not actually going to
lose on time so it's basically like for
the next 10 20 moves we're going to see
him probably get down possibly to 20
seconds maybe even 10 or less and then
he's going to go back up it's going to
be like a pendulum up and down up and
down we we we were looking at some
position how did we get it Maurice we
were looking at a position like this
though we've got to have a look in the
clock let's get a view of the clock
please guys it's very important that you
have a the camera on he's got 30 look
he's ticking down right 27 seconds so
dramatic A Moment Like This 24 seconds
that's right I I mean and the moment he
makes a move bang he gets new time
attitud is clock and and suddenly he's
got 46 I don't know about that I drama
is totally lost I think you guys are
being a little bit too harsh cuz he's
going to be he can going to continue
it's going to be happen over and over
and over again and that's one of the
nice things about timor's play here that
he knows the pressure is on for his
opponent he can make move in 20 seconds
that's not easy especially when you're a
little worse oh without question and one
of the strange things is because Maurice
uh was showing on his Smartboard that
the computer uh prefers Black's position
but surprising to me not not by the
great amount that I would feel Under
Pressure if as a human player I would
sit there and say I don't like this
position for white the computer says no
it's only slightly better don't panic
and that was a big surprise for me uh
Mar not anymore actually now the last
move that molder played turns out to be
what looks like a serious error and in
the position now yes it turns out that
Knight takes C3 is a beast move Knight
takes C3 smacking down on the board
discover a simple Discovery in fact on
this rook and after Rook takes Rook
simply Knight takes E2 and black has
just won a pawn what looks like for no
reason white might have some counterplay
though with this move ready ready to
take with check and after Knight to D4
he's able to capture here and black can
take this position I don't know that
this is cleanly winning but the knights
are dominant the k Kings powerful this
pass Pawn is thinking of going down the
board this Pawn is hanging looks like a
lot for white to have to think about in
this position it looks like black is
definitely in the driver's seat here
white will have to play precise Chess at
a time when he's got very little time on
the clock but we'll see if he can hang
in here at this moment in the game and
we'll see if gra ends up playing so this
move Knight takes C3 taking advantage of
The Rook on D1 that's hanging so the
idea is if Rook takes
D7 Knight takes E2 as Maurice is saying
spanking down that rook and this Rook on
D7 is hanging and this Knight on C1 well
okay that's protected so The
Rook maybe has to go over here to the G7
Square uh I'm looking there's an E3
check that could be an embarrassment for
a moment but that seems okay
um don't quite see see it yet I'm
looking at Knight takes C1 we've got the
ssion zook Rook takes G6 check King is
nice on D5 but after Bishop takes C1 is
this pass Pawn really going anywhere I'm
not sure I we got E3 check just King E2
looks precisely blockading the pass
that's not really what you wanted at all
no that wasn't what we wanted so let's
go back a second back for sure see if we
can't find a an improved version of this
for black night D4 keeping the Knight on
the board but I'm not convinced by that
one either Rook takes G6 check and white
is keeping material equality and
furthermore after takes on e4 check he
got rid of that uh scary pass
Pawn King Rook takes C4 there still Pawn
on B2 is hanging though
um still uh teor garv uh doing his best
to make make White's life as difficult
as possible and he might not play night
take C3 he's he's thinking here I mean I
I think you know the fact that he's he's
been playing a lot of his moves quickly
the fact that he's going into a think
now I think he's considering it but not
100% that he'll play it because if he
thinks that White's able to consolidate
he might prefer to play moves that
arnest for saying because those are
known to be more pressurizing against a
player in time pressure true I'm just
wondering if can can we throw in the
move E3 check first uh all the similar
idea is that Maurice is talking about
just asking uh why where he wants to put
his King put my king on E1 then I
protect D1 right and then after Knight
C3 I can just play Pawn takes C3 because
you've got your Rook on D1 protected
that's a very important Point uh that
you've mentioned there uh I've got to
move still oh boy I I'm looking at some
crazy line that goes Rook D2 but you
know I don't think that that uh works
sorry uh just fantasy there for a moment
I could go after this a pawn uh I mean
this Knight on C1 really makes a a a bad
impression on my eyes I'm thinking that
I could I could try to play the position
with a peace
sacrifice probably not so let's see E3
King E1 I don't have a good
um continuation here B
B5 B4 trying to open things up uh it's a
critical moment and I don't blame tore
at all for his desire to really get the
Zen of the position and try to uh find
um if it's there a win I think tour
would approve of your use of the word
zen yes he's always into the the latest
Fitness gra Z he does yoga he does yog
skydiving skydiving in Fitness I don't
know exactly how Zen and skydiving goes
he's always uh yeah he just seems like
when you see him he seems like he was on
an raw food diet for a while right he's
kind of always trying the next kind of
holistic Trend he's on the edge he he
really really W likes to stress himself
and really get that adrenaline puming
right by playing uh what he's trying to
play 60 games mind folded
simultaneously he wants to set a record
that's beyond the imagination mace yeah
you go ahead and jump in here for if you
could well it's interesting to watch how
G right now how K is sitting at the
board looking for a move I know a lot of
players in this exact same situation
with the clock ticking down particularly
Muller's really bad time situation they
would absolutely not want to sit they'd
want to move quickly you know how you
try to press somebody who's in time
pressure we've all done it the other gu
low on time even with a 30 second
increment you're thinking man I just
need to make a quick move here quick
move here and you get caught up in the
other person's time pressure but take a
look at gev right now I mean he is
absolutely calm he's just sitting there
looking for a move he just wants a move
he's not going to rush he wants to make
the best move possible because there's
nothing that eats up time more than a
than a really than a really good move
than an exclamation mark of a move I
drop a good move on you yeah you could
have been sitting there thinking as much
as you want you're crying that I played
that particular move and you're still
thinking please don't play that I don't
I haven't found the move yet and so
that's a good habit to get into you see
what an experienced veteran does in this
kind of situation guys agreed and it's
interesting that earlier Yasser you were
talking about how important is to sense
the critical moment well yes gram knows
that he's got tactical possibilities and
therefore it's a good moment to think
because and and big strategic ones as
well yeah I I'm looking at a different a
completely different line E3 checks
there's something about that pawn on E3
that I really do like uh I mean okay
don't blame yet uh that's a that's a
great Pawn the problem is is that I need
to open up things on the queen side and
here I'm thinking about trying to take
advantage of my opponent's time trouble
by making a sudden shift oh are you
going to sacrifice not NE yeah I'm I'm
starting to think about moves like
Knight takes A3 followed by take C3 but
really the first three for one that type
of deal oh well that's a wonderful deal
but I'm also thinking that if I can get
in B5 B4 as well as Rook aana those
types of things that starts to become
very attractive to me too and that's a
kind of move that as you and Maurice are
talking about a time pressure move E3
with the idea of Rook A7
that expected the forcing moves
Mackenzie is no doubt looking at all the
forcing lines so that might just be like
wo i needly
right and again we we just take it one
more look at this idea E3 check King E1
I think that that's a good move by the
way once again uh Jen uh your move Rook
A7 and as white you're thinking gosh
I've got this Knight on the back I want
to bring it out but after you bring your
knight out then this sacrifice of Knight
takes A3 really starts to look marvelous
for black you could capture but then
I've got this Knight Fork uh uh
attacking these Rooks on on E2 and D1
and just wonderful possibilities here
for for uh teamore and I'm sure those
those thoughts are drifting and he's
looking he's about to make a move uh
again this is a a a critical moment 2
minutes for molner 18 and he has chosen
he did not play the uh I can tell I
can't see what he played exactly but I
can tell he did not play um n t
to E6 keeping all the tension in the pos
position is what he did very very at
there you know time pressure
strategy indeed however the the computer
is saying that this move was not optimal
at all in fact it's thinking now that
the position is very close to equal
although not uh not not really equal it
thinks now you could save this Rook get
it off of that square and this Pawn is
under heavy attack and it looks like
he'll have to play E3 check but after
the king moves now this Knight has been
released from prison and this Pawn will
have to be watched forever you'll have
to defend it uh not so easy to
infiltrate into the position so this
move Rook to E6 may not have been the
best move guys all right yeah I mean I
understand the motivation behind the
move you want to keep when your
opponent's in time trouble you want to
keep all the wood on the board and you
want to keep all the tension but Rook E6
is just not one of those moves that
really hits um wait a second we do have
a knight take C3 I think they what was
White's last move let's refresh King G3
King G3 and now that steps into a night
take C3 and boom Oh and they've shaken
hands he's busted after that night take
C3 a horrible mistake that's a shame
that's a shame because he could he could
have been thinking about nc3 on the
previous move when tour was thinking
exactly so he must have missed the
concept altogether so let's go over why
it loses well Knight takes C3 again it's
a it's a double it's a fork against the
two Rooks and that knight uh opened up
the defile so The Rook is threatening to
play Rook D7 takes D1 after this trade
Rook takes D7 there's no trade it's a
check it's a ssen Zug uh tactic an in
between move that come comes with check
thanks to White putting his King on the
worst possible square and after Knight
takes King takes That's All She Wrote uh
black would be an exchange in a pawn up
and it's dead teor Garf plus two chasing
uh Lenderman only half a point ahead
that's right now hey that's a really
good example of how you know you look at
a tactic it doesn't work or you don't
think it works but then your opponent
makes one little tweak and suddenly it
wins instantly and that's why he played
it played it like in a second cuz he had
been analyzing it for 5 minutes prior
exactly fin thought for Maurice may I
add guys that uh the increment didn't
help him in this case either he just
blundered in time pressure anyway uh so
a win by gev that's a big deal in this
tournament because now GV has separated
himself from the other contenders and he
is now only half a point behind behind
uh Lenderman the leader so three and a
half in first GV now standing at three
and that puts a lot of pressure on guys
like onuk and kamsky who are looking up
at Two Front Runners one Lenderman
playing very well and gev nobody uh
would be surprised to see him win this
tournament so a very interesting
situation we like the unevenness of the
championship right now I think it makes
for a much more interesting Championship
as we go into the next round it's
absolutely thrilling and you know we
weren't impressed with grav in round one
but he's starting to make up for it
right he's playing some pretty
enterprising chess and going for it all
the way two and a half out of three
after that horrendous game one that's
right and so round four of the US Chess
Championship was a pretty bloody one so
the men did make up for the women and we
hope to see more of that tomorrow we're
going to have round five of the US Chess
Championship and round four of the US
Women's Championship we're predicting a
lot of blood on the board you don't want
to miss it I'm Jennifer shahadi and I'm
here with grandm yaser Saran and Maurice
Ashley and we hope to see you all
tomorrow
great